here in Marrakesh government leaders
from nearly 150 countries are meeting
today to adopt the UN Global Compact for
migration but for Belgian Prime Minister
Sharma she'll the price for taking part
in the summit has been the collapse of
his governing coalition Belgium's
right-wing new Flemish Alliance one of
the country's four coalition partners
fiercely opposes the non-binding pact
they quit the government in protest
defended the norm spread I find it very
unfortunate that we can't come to an
agreement
if the pact is non-binding and therefore
not terribly important why not simply
reject it Prime Minister Michelle
decided to fly to Marrakesh despite
ongoing disputes with the Flemish
nationalists last week a majority of the
Belgian Parliament voted in favor of
signing the UN pact during the
parliamentary debate a large majority
more than two-thirds voted to support
this agreement there were big majorities
across all English the groups in support
of this Accord which provides a tool to
responsibly manage migration issues the
collapse of his coalition now leaves
Michel at the helm of a minority
government with parliamentary elections
not scheduled until May Belgium may be
forced to hold an early vote